firing on all four and thousands of you
have been literally thousands of you
have been sending us the questions you'd
like us to put to the education
secretary and former vaccines minister
on your behalf by email by twitter and
instagram will get going in 60 seconds
we want as many people as possible to
take up the offer of a vaccine against
covert 19.
this is real progress
but we know there's more much more to do
[Music]
okay i'm just hearing in nadeem saharawi
education circle uh okay mr zahawi have
been allies and supporters of boris
johnson for many years
i am the secretary for education
newly appointed by
my boss prime minister
[Music]
whether you're recently retired or
trained as a teacher and have moved
profession i urge you to consider
whether you might be able to spare even
a day a week
exams in summer going ahead full speed
quite a build up wasn't it
here we go here we go we've had so many
questions so let's start off with this
first one it's a video report
school infections are very high in
england at the moment are you sure it's
the right decision to not make masks
mandatory in schools and are you looking
at any additional measures to protect
children
so that's a bead and he's saying um
should we not uh enforce mask wearing in
schools and any further protection
so a really good question from abby uh
if you remember when omikron
hit us we went to plan b plan b included
masks and communal areas in schools um i
went further because i looked at the
evidence from uk
health security agency and of course
some of the work we did in the
department we did an observational study
of schools had which had used mass in
the classroom so further than just in
communal parts and we did that um to
make sure that the reopening of schools
um in january went as smoothly as we
could make it and of course we had
schools order test kits that uh
secondary school children can be tested
in that first week we had something like
28 million test kits go out
another 17 million by end of january
now all of that has meant that 99.9 of
schools are open
um we're seeing um actually attendance
begin to tick upwards so we're at 89
attendance ninety-nine point nine
percent as i say are open
i think
the balance because we know that masks
in the classroom
does inhibit learning but much harder uh
to communicate much more difficult for
children to learn and i think now we're
at a stage where we're probably going to
be one of the first major economies in
the world to transition this virus from
pandemic to endemic i think it's right
that we removed masks in the classroom
as soon as we could and as the prime
minister said yesterday the dispatch box
that on the 21st
of february when we're back after half
term he will set out the plan of how
we're going to live with covert and if
the data continues to move in the right
direction because we are data driven
then we will remove all restrictions a
month early we will come back to that um
but we've got so many questions to go
through this is from joanne taylor
i live in extra care
care managers here have been and are
really struggling to recruit carers and
catering staff bending over backwards
the vulnerable being held back
repeatedly from learning so in leveling
up for inequality why not extend the
vital help being deployed to hospitals
currently by our armed forces to within
our care sector also
great question
really great question and i know that
the health secretary
has been paying a lot of attention to
the case if he's put hundreds of
millions of more funding to make sure
that the care sector can um
get over the sort of the the
challenge of
omicron and of course people being off
sick and that staffing challenge um
that's happening and i know that he will
do everything in his power to make sure
that that support continues to be in
place
for the care sector it's an important
sector you remember during the
vaccination program you showed my clip
as the vaccine minister we focus very
much um in the first phase of the
vaccination program on getting into care
homes and getting those most vulnerable
protected as quickly as possible but i
know the health secretary is looking to
make sure whatever he can do to to um
mitigate against the the staff shortages
he's doing but um reducing you were
talking about the self-isolation and the
fact that it could end a month early i
mean what is that actually based on is
it is it going to be based on the
science there's a yuga poll that says
that 75 of britons want the rules that
are in place at the moment to remain as
such 48 percent from them forever
well
as i said we're going to be
led by the data so if the data continues
to move in the right direction so if i
look at my own uh department um we look
at attendance uh data and absenteeism
data um then we are in a better place
this week than we were uh but what about
the number of people who are actually um
contracting it
so again of course
we'll be led by the data at the moment
um as i did when i got omicron i
self-isolated immediately and then
waited until um i tested negative twice
and then
before i could actually come out of
isolation i couldn't come out on day
five or six because i was still testing
positive i had it quite severely um in
many ways the important thing is is that
we follow the data and what the primes
are saying is on the 21st he will come
to parliament set out the plan for
living with covert and if the data
continues to move in the direction it's
moving in at the moment then we will be
able to um by the 24th um a month early
be able to to um effectively ask you
about that given that we that you
brought up your code and you had it
quite severely if you i know you're
fully jabbed um and you've had it before
i'm guessing so no it's my first time
okay so how can you contract it if
you've had all these three vaccines how
do you convince people that it's a good
idea to have the vaccinations
all i can say to your viewers is i think
without the vaccine and the booster i'd
have had it
even worse my doctor said
uh because it's your physiology and as
you reminded me and i knew this when i
was vaccinated minister that it's your
your body's reaction to covet that
you know will determine how severe or
asymptomatic you might be i've had you
know family members who had no symptoms
whatsoever
in my case it got worse it got into my
chest and i had to sort of uh
increase the the sort of level of
medical help i needed um
but he said
by day four five it got into my chest
and started
really
affecting my breathing and he found it
difficult to breathe
medication and then he said one more day
and i might have to put you on two
steroids or something else that's
heavier but it luckily started to then
recover my temperature went up to nine
thirty nine point five oh yeah no it
wasn't was not pleasant but he reminded
me and he said you know whenever you go
on
case program
that if you hadn't had the vaccines and
the booster he said i guarantee you you
had been in hospital and probably
intubated
that's not a good sign is that because
if you need to get your vaccine and get
your booster it's never too late
the the offer is evergreen from the nhs
if you haven't had a vaccination go and
get your vaccine i promise you this
thing is not like a cold it's not like a
mild flu if it hits you severely
and you're one of the unlucky ones it is
horrific it's not good you think you
could have died if you hadn't had the
vaccines i i certainly if i hadn't had
the vaccine i would have been in
in
big trouble um according to my doctor
okay thankfully you did and you're here
uh let's uh move on to school
ventilation should we this is from
nicola cackett she says all my nieces
classroom windows have to remain open to
ventilate the room but there's only one
small radiator in the room my niece is
wearing thermal leggings under several
layers of clothes and keeping her coat
on in class and it's still cold all day
would your cabinet sit under these
conditions
uh nicola so what we did is we sent out
350 000 co2 monitors to make sure that
pretty much all the classrooms in our
schools are monitored we then got the
data back and did our own
modeling
that suggested that probably around 9
000
air filtration units air purifiers will
be needed so we ordered those and those
are going out to the schools that can't
easily
ventilate but actually if you look at
what we did with schools
the vast majority were able to
cope and
effectively ventilate classrooms
relatively easily
but those that couldn't i made sure we
had the air purifiers by opening the
windows but i mean we're looking at
times educational supplement magazine
talking about one particular school uh
fifty thousand pounds for one month's
electricity use and thirteen thousand
pounds for gas um 54 000 pounds higher
than the amount it normally would have
to fork out
absolutely one part of the
thing that i'm doing at the moment is
making sure we
in the department um keep our eye on
the cost of energy in the education
estate now the good news is the new
schools we're building we're building
500 new schools they're all at net zero
operation they are really unbelievably
energy efficient but that's yeah we
still have twenty four thousand three
hundred plus school so uh it puts it in
in perspective where we're trying to
sort of mitigate um for those schools
that we can um but we're keeping an eye
as well on the energy uh costs and the
pressure we had a good settlement during
the spending review in terms of uh
school budget so for secondary schools
we're at uh six thousand one hundred
fifty pounds per pupil and for primary
we're at four thousand eight hundred
pounds more than they normally pay is
that something you look at we we are
looking and making sure we're monitoring
the the cost of energy in in schools and
the impact potentially on on schools so
the one thing we did on uh part of the
covert um mitigations
is a fund back to the question around um
uh social care similar for schools for
if they needed temporary staff to help
with um staff shortages we put a fund
together but
we made sure that sr as well we actually
got a good funding settlement because we
we
knew
that actually the cost of things like
energy was going to to go up okay i have
to move on this literally several
questions we this is holly stafford um
holly has written this question for you
secretary of state where's the catch-up
tutoring we were promised my daughter is
in her gcse year and has received
nothing
holly
get in contact with
your school every school has the
opportunity to
take up the tutoring program
we are
first term this year have done as many
tutoring hours as the whole of last year
we are committed to doing six million
tutoring uh programs of 15 hour uh
courses for children the center of its
target at the moment well
no because actually if you there are
three pillars and
whether it's the times education
supplement or somewhere else that
mentioned that they only looked at one
of the pillars so we've got
three pillars one is school led tutoring
which is the most successful because
schools told us actually why don't you
just give us the money and we will you
know hire in a tutor that we think is is
the right
uh individual uh to help children
recover um uh from uh the the covert
catch up kevin collins i mean lots of
people well just you don't know how
obviously former education catch-ups are
uh he quit uh last june uh saying that
the plans for pupils were feeble
well
one
my very strong view is you invest and
then you evidence uh what you do so
we're making a five billion pound
investment in recovery now what i did
was i looked at the evidence the
evidence is that those as with the
question just now
with the least time left in education so
16 to 19 year olds need the most
effort so i went to the chance and i
said look i need 800 million for
recovery for the 16 to 19 year olds he
gave me that and then i wanted more
money for secondary primary for
disadvantaged children again because
it's important that we focus on
disadvantaged children to make sure they
recover as well and he gave me that
which is why we managed to get the total
to 5 billion now
tutoring is a really important part of
that
we'll do six million tutoring uh blocks
of 15 hours each 100 million hours in
total every school uh is eligible to
come forward and have
uh you know a part of that funding for
the national tutoring program i want
them to come forward i'm parents and i'm
writing to parents to say look you know
contact your school and find out if they
are taking advantage of the national
tutoring program
and then make sure that actually i
monitor
have we caught up have we recovered if
we haven't i'll go back to treasury and
ask for more money because what i want
to do is by the end of this parliament
is make sure that every child has had
the opportunity to recover okay
perhaps one of the ways to do that is
more homework or not raquel dealey has
written to us this morning morning
racquel if you're watching my son is 11
and currently completes anywhere from
two to three hours of homework every
night what is the education secretary's
view on how much homework is acceptable
for each student in a secondary school
what happens in your house
uh mia does a lot of work uh where's
your little girl that's she's nine um
the boys are now grown up and graduated
um but
i mean two to three hours is too much
two to three hours is a lot of homework
i think in many ways i suspect raquel um
that the school is
rightly focused on recovery and catch-up
and i was at hammersmith academy a few
weeks ago to see the brilliant work that
the leadership team did gary kinnison is
a brilliant head teacher you should have
him on this program okay we will um but
um they were saying to me look the way
we're dealing with recovery is to see
where the gaps are and then really focus
on those for those kids so uh the best
thing that rachel can do is talk to uh
the uh her
son or daughter's teacher uh to you
acknowledge that it's too much to do i i
think it's look we've got to trust our
teachers and our head teachers they know
best if i sit on your program and
pronounce on racquel's you know uh
child's uh homework
you will think that everybody in the
profession will think i'm you know the
one he says he's the evidence led
secretary of state yet he's arrogantly
pronouncing on this stuff the reality is
the teachers know best what each child
needs to recover and i think they're
doing a great job in delivering okay
raquel i don't think you need to do two
he doesn't need to do two three hours of
homework and i i had a little boy and i
would not have had him doing that no
matter what the education secretary is
saying this morning i think he's half
agreeing with you anyway uh what about
this from helen this is helen uh why
have private schools been using teacher
assessments under covid as an excuse to
boost their grades the sunday times
reports that in one case their a star
rate went from 33 percent
to 90 last summer
i saw that report and in fact
this week
uh i had the regulatory off call and i
discussed this with them and they
reassured me a couple of things and i
want to just reassure the viewers on
this
one is that uh every allegation
is investigated by the exam boards and
all the records have been kept so none
of the records of the teacher
assessments
have been um destroyed or gone away so
if there are any new allegations they
will investigate them as well they also
reassured me that that actually when you
look at whether it's independent schools
or academies uh the children who were
expected to get
high grades a grades actually
achieved those every head teacher had to
sign a you know really really stringent
um uh
letter of verification that they
followed the assessment correct
a star grade at a level reached 39.5 in
2021 compared to 16
in 2019
something going on there well and and we
we saw which is why
i want to go back to exams and which is
why i'm determined to go back to exams
for gcse's a s and a levels this summer
um look there is no perfect system all i
can say is from all the evidence the
best system we have is have going back
to examinations we're doing that
sensitively we're doing it in a way that
recognizes that children's education has
been disrupted um at the beginning of
the week
off call actually put out through uh the
exam boards further information as to
what the the content of the exams will
be to help those uh children preparing
for their exams i think that's the right
thing we're not leaping back to
pre-covered
grading because i think that would also
be unfair we're doing it in two steps so
going halfway and then this summer and
then going back to pre-covert next year
that's also i think important so these
mitigations i think recognize the
disruption but i think examination is
the best way
of making sure we deliver rigor
it's also saying that you know if you
leave it to her teachers and and
teachers more generally then they're
easing up those grades well look
as i say we we saw
some of that great inflation come
through because it was
um you know teacher assessed we're going
back to examination i think that's the
right thing to do the um information
landed really positively on monday and i
think the feedback from the sector from
across you know from the front line has
been really positive and students want
to go back they make their preparations
they want to go back and and and have
taken the exam whether it's gcses or a
levels okay well coming up to um 20 past
nine we're ripping through those but
still so many um to go this one
obviously that is talking about state
education this is from david west david
good morning to you david wants to know
uh a year's fee to attend eaton is 44
000 pounds
how does that institution deserve
charity status that exempts it from a
whole range of taxes
so
the independent sector 50 of them have
charitable uh status including um
including eaton um i want to see
uh those schools do much more um uh to
uh open up to children from
disadvantaged backgrounds they're doing
a lot already they want to do more with
us on um our journey which is the really
my focus uh which is a system that is
diverse so we have
academies we have free schools we have
independent sector that's a good thing i
think in an education
system they want to do more on that
journey where we get
every child to have a great education in
every part of the country at the right
time in the right place
but i think it's also important that
they play their part
what does that look like
well
you know can we
get
our independent schools to join us on
what the evidence suggests is the best
way forward which is a family of schools
that are well managed you know tightly
managed really well supported in a
multi-academy trust that's high
performing that we know the evidence
just delivers the best outcome for every
child i always tell my story when i
arrived on these shows at the age of 11.
i couldn't speak a word of english but i
had parents who valued
education my mother was a dentist in
iraq and they pushed me hard i want the
system to deliver for the child whose
parents don't have that wherewithal
everywhere you know whether you're in
blackpool or london or manchester or
birmingham that every school delivers a
great quality education and i've got the
evidence of how we can do it i want
every part of the education sector to
join me on that journey including our
independent schools but if we tax those
independent private schools then there's
1.7 billion pounds available according
to labour for state schools so i saw
that and i also saw some of the analysis
done on this that actually if you do
do that you will um
not increase the tax take for the
exchequer actually go the other way
because many uh uh
parents will will come out of the
independent sector and actually will
will add
to the number of of children that we
would need to accommodate in the state
sector and i think that would be wrong i
follow the evidence i will always be the
evidence-led secretary of state as i did
with with vaccines working you know
cross-party with
sadiq khan who i know you've had on your
program and andy burnham and andy street
in birmingham i will always follow the
evidence is not there on this having a
diverse ecosystem of education with you
know the the
academy program being
clearly evidence you know the the best
way of organizing a family of schools um
if they're really well supported not
every academy by the way
does well there are some schools in
academies that coast i'm going to deal
with that especially through the
leveling up white paper with michael
gove in those educational investment
areas we announced uh but a lot of work
to do but i think we've got the evidence
to deliver a system that delivers for
every child okay you touched on this but
um etrus um has said been good enough to
send us a question so i perhaps you
could reiterate your thoughts on this
why are the 2022 exams still going ahead
we've missed a year of learning due to
covert many topics haven't been taught
with further disruptions that only
months towards the actual exams gcses
are setting my year up for failure let
teachers graders they know what they're
capable of
i trust
i think that the best way
to assess um a student's work is through
examination there's no perfect way but
what i've tried to do
is be sensitive to the fact that your
education has been disrupted which is
why
we on monday
through the exam boards made more
information available as to what
you'll be examined on whether you're
doing a gcse as or an a level
so the subject matter is much clearer
for your teachers so they can focus on
those uh parts of the subject that will
be in the examination
we are being more generous with the
grading we're not going back to
pre-covert grading this year we're going
halfway and then we'll we'll go to
pre-covert the year after um
i think all those mitigations are the
right things because they recognize that
disruption that you've been through um i
thank every student for the resilience
they've shown we've just done our survey
state of the nation survey of students
and they've seen unbelievable resilience
um including some real pressure on
well-being and mental health as well as
of course um you know recovery in their
education but real resilience and i
thank you for that but examination is
the best way and the fairest way forward
okay with that in mind uh mark gower has
sent us uh this video last question for
the education secretary why does the
government have to increase national
insurance contributions for the nhs when
the nhs was promised
315 million a week after leaving the eu
well because we actually made that 350
million available
um after we left the nhs the nhs funding
is is increasing to 36 billion
um
by 36 billion i should say because we
recognize there's a backlog that is
currently at six million could be as
high as uh 11 or 13 million before we
begin to bring it down
plus
so going up for two years yes and
actually more
equally importantly i should say that
adult social care which i know you know
i've been in politics a very long time
that successive governments
have attempted to grapple with it have
then failed and this government under
boris johnson has actually dealt with it
and that national insurance rights yes i
was looking at these figures i mean it's
staggering i'll share them with with the
viewers i'm sure you know already the
nhs accounts for 40
of day-to-day government spending under
labour it was 28
how can we say that the nhs is value for
money well because the nhs had to deal
with a global pandemic um and
that has
in enormous consequences whether it is
what we did with vaccines um which
actually now is making us one of the
most dynamic economies
in the world will probably be one of the
first major economies in the world to
transition this virus from pandemic to
enemy thanks to the nhs but the nhs also
you know with
the the the focus of the prime minister
has
come up with a uh adult social care
strategy that will finally work and not
break people in old age uh where we know
this this is you know pretty harrowing
for families when they have two money is
that what you're saying i i think the
nhs delivers great uh work
they can always improve the if you ask
the nhs leadership they're the first to
say that actually reform is good look at
what we did
again with vaccine the data we went to
you know from sort of fortnightly to
weekly to daily data real granularity by
postcode by
ethnicity by um you know
lots of different ways to cut and slice
the data so that we can see who is being
vaccinated where and where we need to
focus resources data and transparency is
our ally on this journey to get real
reform in the nhs and to deliver better
outcomes in any complex system right the
best way you can deal with it is if you
measure everything and publish it
because people then can see
and then the system will become more
human and improve we've got time for a
few more i hope so i hope so including
fred syriacs from first dates more from
him in just a second but first this is
jane talking about long covered
my daughter has been battling with long
covid since march 2020
she's only in school six hours a week on
the doctor's orders and has had to drop
to just two gcses because her body can't
cope with the exam process
what will the government do to support
these children within a discriminatory
system
probably something like 120 000 kids in
that position
and and one of the things that we've
actually i met um some students through
first news um when they came to see me
in the department and um newspaper for
the absolute and which has a
collaboration with sky news um
and um
who was she was telling me about her
struggle with long cove which is why
um
under matt hancock when i was back in
the health department
we put
serious amounts of funding into
the research into long covert and
helping gps understand and identify uh
long covert because actually much of
this is about diagnosis and then that
would then allow the whole system the
the education system and the healthcare
system to work together to be able to
help those children okay um we talked we
certainly touched on special education
needs um earlier on i don't want to hear
what jack has to say
ask someone with an awesome diagnosis i
wasn't given the support i needed at
school i was quite misunderstood which
led to me being excluded which had an
impact on my education
so i'd like to ask the education
secretary what are the government's
plans to ensure that children who have a
learning difficulty or a developmental
disability are being provided with
adequate support in schools and that
there needs a map handsome young man
isn't he hi jack a very good morning if
you're watching do you feel that you're
letting people like jack down i think
we're gonna do more for jack so one of
the things that i'm doing is the um
send the special educational needs and
disabilities review uh and i'll be
publishing
basically i'm looking at the whole
system um to see how we can deliver
better outcomes for uh jack and for his
education and his family and his health
so
you know the the reforms that we
delivered when we first came to office
in the coalition government were good
that children can have an uh education
health and care plan
but we need to revisit those to i think
make sure that they're working
everywhere and they're working
consistently now that's my sort of
review the green paper as uh we call it
in in westminster jargon
but i didn't wait for that i also went
to the chancellor at the spending review
and i said look we need
more money because we need more places
more sufficiency in the system now and
so he gave us 2.6 billion to invest in
more places for
specialist places
as well as mainstream places because i
think you need both what would you say
to jack specifically when he feels that
he'd been let down i say sorry and i say
i will do better i promise you one of
the opportunities i have is the stars of
a line nicely i've got a school's white
paper which we will publish next month
which will
outline my vision for the education
system and how we deliver that great you
know education for every child at the
right place at the right time in every
part of the country but with it i've got
the children's social care review and
the scnd review and actually for the
first time in department education we
can actually knit all three together
because you need for children with
special educational needs you need the
school system to be equally responsible
as the healthcare system
needs to be it's not just kids that are
struggling at school this is um from
richard from bedfordshire hi richard he
um has written to us to say my wife is a
head teacher in a small rural lower
school performing the duties of seven
other people working until nine or ten
o'clock most nights on the verge of some
kind of breakdown what is a school
supposed to do when a class has three
pupils with specific requirements and no
support staffed due to sickness
richard i
through you richard i want to thank your
wife because that these are the sort of
stories
that uh you know make me feel that we've
got it though
which is why we're putting so much
effort to make sure that you know you
saw in your clip when we started the
program of my
call for retirees to come forward for
this period when we're dealing with the
pandemic as we transition that omicron
hit us hard especially on on staffing uh
and actually what um richard's wife has
done is fantastic i've seen it is it
going to get easier
it will be
one obviously
because as we
transition this virus as we see
infection rates begin to drop
further we're seeing um uh teacher
absence also beginning to tick down um
we're at nine
percent absence in the system uh this
week which is a tick down a little bit
needs to come down further um then
things will get better and better and of
course supply teachers are an important
part of that which is why you know my my
big call before christmas to say anyone
who can volunteer come forward um joined
the supply agencies uh did and we
actually uh did a call around about 10
supply agencies and found that around
500 people had actually come forward
from just the 10 percent of the agencies
which is good which means there's at
least a few more thousand people who
wouldn't have come forward uh who came
forward still not enough still feel yeah
that's an inadequate ounce of rich's
wife i just want to say thank you from
the bottom of my heart because 99.9
of schools are open because of people
like rich's wife and the support that
she gives those children
do you ever watch um first dates on
channel four yeah
yes well he's got a question for you
let's do it let's do it
we only have about 130 catering colleges
in total in the uk
this is not enough to produce the
necessary manpower to sustain
hospitality let alone grow it
so what is the plan for professional
education
thanks fred
great question and one of the first
visits i made was westminster kings who
have a brilliant catering
program
in their college really fantastic but we
need more
and um i don't have enough waiting stuff
don't see it as a job as a career they
just see it as something to do as a
transition and fred's saying that's not
good enough absolutely right which is
why my big focus and we are in national
apprenticeship week this week um is to
make sure that we continue to invest in
apprenticeships we're going to raise
rich is giving us 2.7 billion by 2024 uh
to invest in uh apprenticeships that's
good we want to see more of those in
hospitality industry and i want to see
some we now have some of the best brands
of restaurants and hotels in the united
kingdom they all need more staff high
quality training is so important to this
what are you gonna do and so i want them
to come forward we will do everything in
our power in the department to
facilitate
making this happen we're just doing a
similar thing in the creative industry
with the bbc actually tim davey came to
see me it was going so well until you
said that i'm sorry i am sorry but
they've they've done it
they're great because actually in many
ways creative industries has lots of
long tail of small businesses who might
not themselves want an apprenticeship
you know full-time and so having having
the ability to have that uh you know
part-time and sharing of of
apprenticeships is really important for
the creation so fred can reach out to
you and fred come and see me i will i
absolutely want to see him i've seen
other sort of major players in the
hospitality industry who want to do the
same uh in you know in birmingham and in
other parts of the country where they
want to you know maybe build a a a a new
facility a bigger facility okay for the
catering industry i'll put you two
together then uh right this is a a text
from everyone knows dave i'm not sure i
do but we'll go with it dave
what number do you get when you subtract
the number of resignations in the past
few days from the number of parties
investigated by sue gray see where he's
going with that the answer is apparently
11. um but you know we saw the picture
in the daily mirror yesterday didn't we
with the prime minister with the
champagne at one of those parties um how
damaging is what's been going on at
downey street for you guys
so look i think there is no doubt that
uh you know the
stories around uh parties have cut
through and people uh were rightly angry
to see that those who were making the
rules
um
have allegations put against them that
they're not obeying the rules i think
the police are
looking at all those um uh allegations
that sue grey has given them i think
they've got a reel and a half hundreds
of pages of uh report and pictures to
look at i think it's only right dave
that they should do that and do their
work properly and then i'll happily
submit myself to k burley and come and
and and explain and and answer any
questions necessary in terms of our
focus i can tell you skills schools
family is my focus we're delivering
we're we're in national apprenticeship
week this week we've had mental health
week
really really focused delivery in my
department similarly in
other departments across government
whether it's transport or
in department for energy on the the cost
of living uh christ then the spike in
gas prices globally that we've seen you
know the focus of this government is to
recover the economy from covid
make sure that we recover the nhs more
doctors more nurses more police officers
uh on our doorstep
and make sure that we uh deliver
the the the outcomes that people want to
see um for their children um because the
best way to level up the most valuable
resource on earth is the human resource
and if i can deliver the great education
for every child in our country the
opportunities i had to sit before you as
secretary of state for education um for
every child and i would have done
something truly great that is my focus
dave i promise you that is what i spend
all of my time on okay be pleased to
know that these are not my questions
today so i will not be grilling you on
that but i will
in the fullness of time let me leave it
to david um craigs he says he describes
himself as a former conservative member
and he says as education secretary what
sort of example do you think the prime
minister's behaviour sets for young
people and what effect do you think your
continued support and close association
with him
um has on your reputation
so david i take the view that you treat
everybody with respect you share the
evidence with them uh you explain what
you're trying to achieve
and i think most people will then
you know
i hope join in the endeavor and on that
journey that's what i'm seeing across
the board
whether i'm working
with
teachers and head teachers
our universities or
our colleges
that is what i see i've always done that
the prime minister my
dealings with him has always
dealt with me respectfully and always
engaged on the evidence and has backed
me when i said to him you know
i don't know what i've told you this
story but
you know in the middle of the
vaccination program
we had an offer from pfizer biontic to
say we can offer you now but you have to
make a decision in a week uh for
vaccines that you may need if there's a
variant that you'd need to boost against
in the winter but you have to tell us
now
so months earlier
seven months uh before
um the advice some of the advice was we
don't need it we're absolutely fine
because this thing won't need a booster
um i went to the pm and said actually i
think we really should take this just in
case and he took that decision without
that decision
1.6 billion a lot of money oh wow a lot
of money uh but but nevertheless he took
that without that decision we would
never have a booster campaign i promise
you that dave right and so on the big
calls
this prime minister has got them right
whether you know
delivering brexit i mean i remember the
pain of the last government where the
parliament was paralyzed we couldn't do
anything but we delivered brexit on the
first vaccination program to get the
first vaccine approved anywhere in the
world with pfizer beyond tech i remember
that the first 8th of december was the
date we delivered that first jab
in the uk then the booster campaign and
now
the omicron pre-christmas there were
lots of advice saying lock down lock
down lock down harder right he said no
i'm looking at the evidence we don't
need to because we will destroy
ourselves we'll destroy the economy harm
people's mental well-being if we look
down on the big calls he got them right
well he's you know he came to parliament
apologized you know we've made a mistake
and he came back again um
after sue gray's publication and said
it's not good enough to just say we made
him say we've got to change and he's
making those changes now well we'll see
what happens when the police report back
just as far as astrazeneca is concerned
quite a lot of criticism for the
astrazeneca is it is it does it do what
it says on the tin yes it does it's a
great vaccine
and i tell you for why because if you
look at what we've been able to do in
the uk both remember vaccines
have
an impact both on
your antibody levels and t cells and t
cells are sort of more uh dormant in in
your body and they sort of awaken when
the virus hits and they really begin to
help you fight the virus and
astrological has done brilliantly uh for
us here in the uk and i've had two
astrological vaccines followed by a
pfizer booster that's a really good uh
combination uh to have all fisa fires
are followed by fizer or madonna also a
good combination to have but astrazeneca
has been the workhorse of the world over
2.5 billion doses have protected people
around 2.5 billion at no profit
to astrazeneca the oxford team with the
backing of the government with boris
johnson another call from boris to say
we won't take a profit while the
pandemic is with the world uh and that's
gonna agree to that they'll board back
that and agree to that that's a really
great thing i'm incredibly proud of that
okay um this is from um gary i'm not
sure how you'll feel about this question
uh gary mccardle texting will your
horses have to choose between heating or
eating as the upcoming cost of living
bites that's in relation of course to
the fact that you claimed for um heating
your stables as part of your
expenses
and i'm i'm sorry gary and and
i
apologized at the time as soon as i
discovered that um where would it have
happened well i'll tell you what
happened
exactly so we i we brought up a small
holding a a cottage and uh stables that
my wife uh looks after um and um there
was a meter in the stables a meter at
the house and um
i thought that um the uh
heating claims that we were making were
uh for the meter reading in the house it
turned out that actually the two meters
were uh connected i ca as soon as i
found out i went to the parliamentary
um uh uh investigator and said look this
is what happened i'm mortified they
looked into it they investigated
thoroughly and they found to be for it
to be a genuine mistake and i apologized
and i uh paid back uh the money and i
and say again
you embarrassed
it's a it's a
stupid thing to have um uh you know
not been able to to spot but um it was a
genuine mistake and as soon as i found
out i i went to the uh parliamentary uh
to ipsa and and explained look
here's the evidence here's here's what
happened i'm sorry that was then this is
now um and we were speaking to sadiq
khan um yesterday um
and this is what he said about you
nadeem sahari is the best adjacent
secretary in the last 11 years good
example of of a labour politician
saying good things about a tory
politician and one of the things about
nadine i met him two weeks ago is uh he
puts aside part of politics and works
for the common good and he's also quite
interested in fun so good luck with that
that's nice that is nice it's really i
tell you what's been
truly remarkable and it's something that
i think we need to do more of
uh is in the vaccination program um i
worked with siddique in london and andy
burnham manchester and andy street in
birmingham all the other
mayors around the country
i briefed them regularly we worked
together i shared the evidence with them
and they all stepped up when i was
children vaccines were the children uh
minister uh under theresa may before
vaccines uh children family minister we
did tremendous work with andy burnham on
um those in care and those who are
leaving care care leave the covenant he
really helped me lead on that uh andy
burnham it's that sort of collaboration
if you follow the evidence we're doing
the same now on skills so the local
skills improvement plans i'll be working
with uh siddique and uh the other mayors
to make sure that we get the local
skills improvement plans uh around the
country right that's a bottom-up
approach to what skills needs
uh are necessary in the economy and then
i've also launched the unit for future
skills which is something that
singapore's had for many years we don't
have that in the uk where we'll be able
to pull in data from everywhere hmrc
from student loan book companies so we
can see what the skills needs of the
economy are next two years five years
ten years so that i can then flex the
infrastructure i spent 86 billion a year
in education
i can flex all that infrastructure to
where the economy needs those skills
what does that do it gives those kids
the real opportunity for a great
education and a great job at the end of
it and the name's zahawi nadim zahawi
and you're going to pinewood later on
you know where they failed you see what
i did there not quite double 07.
james bond what's the plan
um so we're gonna get excited about
going i'm very excited about going uh
we're gonna look at their apprenticeship
program they've done a brilliant uh
apprenticeship program uh there so we're
gonna have a look i've signed an nda so
i can't talk about what they're gonna
show oh how exciting
it's it's a big blockbuster um uh
production that they've they've got on
that they're going to show me uh oh i i
get a behind the scenes fantastic peak
at the work they're doing but it's been
a
number 10 wasn't it this was yeah with
the bt apprentices uh that was earlier
this week they are phenomenal
i tell you what great ambassadors for
the apprenticeship program any family
watching this program if your kids are
thinking about you know the future
whether it's you know did they do a
levels and what they want to do think
about a t level we're going to make t
levels that's famous that's right for
tory leader now not toury leader
it's it's it's t level so i'm going to
make t levels as famous as a levels t
levels i hear you ask are
a fusion between an apprenticeship and
an a level okay and you can either go to
university with them i think we've got
16 institutions now accepting
t levels or you can go and work and have
a great career with t levels so we're
doing microsoft t levels we're doing
lots of other uh t levels they are going
to be as famous as a levels if i do my
job right okay and unless i let you go
i'm going to be in a lot of trouble with
your team so i must let you go but 45
minutes of questions out of thousands
that we received and answered them
honestly and openly and we very much
appreciate it thank you very much indeed
for joining us secretary of state thank
you thank you uh very much coming up in
just a second or two tomorrow's take on
our interview this morning with the
secretary of state um as i said he was
very honest he was very open uh with us
and you can check it out
on our ipad if you would like to and of
course we'll be clipping it up for you
and hearing some of those uh in more
detail
in just a few moments time before that
though tamara has been listening um very
honest very open i think he was a lot
for parents and teachers who are
wondering where we go now with covid
with removal of all restrictions but as
we know hundreds of thousands of
children off school every week
continuing to flight their education two
years on a lot to get into there i
thought we started off with interesting
revelation though okay about nadim
zahawi's own experience of covid despite
being triple vaccinated he had covered
very seriously last week had to take
strong medication and when you asked him
whether he could have died he said if he
hadn't been vaccinated then there was a
serious risk this is what he told us
i've had you know family members who had
no symptoms whatsoever
in my case it got worse it got into my
chest and i had to sort of
uh
increase the the sort of level of
medical help i needed um but he said
by day four five it got into my chest
and it started
really
affecting my breathing and he found it
difficult to
medication and then he said one more day
and i might have to put you on two
steroids or something else that's
heavier but it luckily started to then
recover my temperature went up to nine
thirty nine point five oh yeah no it
wasn't was not pleasant do you think he
could have died if you hadn't had the
vaccines
certainly if i hadn't had the vaccine i
would have been in
in big trouble um according to my doctor
my goodness me but thankfully he has now
made a full recovery which is why he
wasn't here actually on monday because
he was still recovering still testing
positive he also talked about um
homework yes interesting hard to pin
down when nadeem zahawi sits on the
spectrum between michael gover's
education secretary wanting to go back
to rigorous uh learning to cut out some
of what he saw as softer subject and
then resource of gavin williamson
battling through the pandemic nadim
zahawi asked how much homework children
should be doing he said that it was for
teachers to set it out but he had a
sense that two and a half to three hours
might be a bit too much
two to three hours is a lot of homework
i think in many ways i suspect raquel um
that the school is
rightly focused on recovery and catch up
look we've got to trust our teachers and
our head teachers they know best if i
sit on your program and pronounce on
racquel's you know child's uh homework
you will think that everybody in the
profession will think i'm you know the
one he says he's the evidence led
secretary of state yet he's arrogantly
pronouncing on this stuff the reality is
the teachers know best what each child
needs to recover and i think they're
doing a great job
talked about private schools um being
treated as charities as well labour have
got a view on that and if they private
schools were taxed then there'd be an
awful lot more for the state education
system he didn't necessarily think that
was the case that's right nadine zahari
was privately educated himself
this idea that private schools should
not have charitable status they should
pay more taxes one that labour have
labor promised at the last election but
tory politicians have toyed with it as
well they say you could make 1.7 billion
but
other analysis including by hmrc shows
that the problem with is is if you raise
the fees a bit the smaller private
schools go bust all those children need
to go into the state sector and you end
up
spending more money than you save so
it's an interesting balance there nadim
zaha we said he didn't believe the
evidence supported it and so he would
want to
keep private schools funded the way they
are
i want to see
those schools do much more um
to
open up to children from disadvantaged
backgrounds they're doing a lot already
they want to do more with us on
our journey which is the really my focus
we tax
independent private schools then there's
1.7 billion pounds available according
to labour for state schools so i saw
that and i also saw some of the analysis
done on this that actually if you do
do that
you will
not increase the tax take for the
exchequer actually go the other way
because many uh
parents will will come out of the
independent sector and actually will
will add
to the number of of children that we
would need to accommodate in the state
sector and i think that would be wrong i
follow the evidence i will always be the
evidence-led secretary of state i will
always follow the evidence is not there
on this
um interesting that he was talking i
mean one of the questions was about the
horse we've got a lot of questions
from our viewers um he claimed to heat
his stables that that's always been a
problem that's right so nadim zahawi who
now is being spoken of as a potential
leadership candidate if a contest uh was
to happen if you look back when he's
been in the news before 2013 uh sort of
fall out from the expenses scandal and
he was told to repay
almost 6 000 pounds he had charged the
taxpayer to heeta stables which was
adjoining his constituency home in
warwickshire and he claims it was a
genuine error the bill was put all
together he said he was mortified and he
had paid the money back this is what he
told us
as soon as i found out i went to the
parliamentary
investigator and said look this is what
happened i'm mortified they looked into
it they investigated thoroughly and they
found to be for it to be a genuine
mistake and i apologized and i uh paid
back uh the money and i i said again
gary
are you embarrassed
it's it's a stupid thing to to have um
uh you know
not been able to to spot but um it was a
genuine mistake and as soon as i found
out i i went to the uh parliamentary uh
to ipsa and and explained
saturday it was a genuine mistake he
told us um now he is always defending
boris johnson as well as the party
is concerned well big supporter of boris
johnson is nadim zahawi but great
question about what message the prime
minister's behaviour setting the rules
and then apparently breaking them sends
to school children and to head teachers
who we know have been contacting local
mps saying you know what kind of message
does this sent out this is was his
answer
the
stories around uh parties have cut
through and people
were rightly angry to see that those who
were making the rules um
have allegations put against them that
they're not obeying the rules i think
the police are
looking at all those um uh allegations
that sue grey has given them i think
they've got a reel and a half hundreds
of pages of uh report and pictures to
look at i think it's only right dave
that they should do that and do their
work properly and then i'll happily
submit myself to kay burley and come and
and and explain and and answer any
questions necessary
plenty of them still waiting um for what
the police have decided that the latest
photograph that we've seen that dropped
um yesterday what do you think overall
he was honest that partygate has really
cut through other cabinet ministers say
it hasn't he showed a lot of humility
about the challenges that teachers and
some children with long covid had faced
during the pandemic he says this is not
a perfect system but in the end he knows
that he will be judged on how they
reduce this enormous attainment gap that
has opened up during the pandemic
between the more and the less advantaged
pupils whether that can close whether
all children who missed out will be able
to recover is going to be the big
challenge for him okay tomorrow thanks
very much indeed thanks a lot so an hour
with the education secretary it wasn't
questions from me it was questions from
you via twitter via instagram via our
inbox here at sky we very much
appreciate you taking the time to submit
those questions and hope you enjoyed it
as much as i did
[Music]
[Music]
you